مرتفع فوق بلدة صغيرة في فرنسا ، توجد
كنيسة صغيرة جميلة ، إنه طريق طويل للوصول إلى
القمة ، لكنك تعلم ما يقولون إنه
كلما كان التسلق أكبر كلما اقتربنا
من شواية سان ميشيل ديا في كنيسة الله
في لو بوي وفوليز وهي بلدة على بعد
ست ساعات تقريبًا  من باريس ، بُنيت
فوق
سدادة بركانية منقرضة يُعتقد أنها تشكلت
منذ أكثر من مليوني عام ، ترتفع هذه الكنيسة على
ارتفاع 300 قدم تقريبًا من
الأرض وهي مخصصة لرئيس الملائكة
ميخائيل ، وقد تم تكليف الكنيسة من قبل
أسقف في عام 951 أراد
إحياء الذكرى  رحلته التي تبلغ ألف ميل
عائداً من سلسلة جبال البيرينيه في
المتوسط ، يستقبل الموقع ما يزيد قليلاً عن 65 أل
زائر كل عام ، وفي 268 خط
ة ، يكون التسلق إلى القمة طويلاً ، لك
المنظر يعد مكافأة رائعة مع نظرة 360 در
ة على المدينة بما في ذل
التكوينات البركانية المحيطة
[موسيقى]